20:20 is already shaping up to be an
incredible year of entertainment thanks
in part to Amazon Prime video whether
you're a fan of the Star Trek franchise
or more terrifying fare like mid Samar
rest assured there's plenty of great
stuff to look forward to in January 2020
if you're a Star Trek fan January 2020
is shaping up to be your month on New
Year's Day you'll be able to stream most
of the franchise films that featured the
original cast Star Trek the motion
picture star trek to the Wrath of Khan
Star Trek 3 the search for Spock Star
Trek 5 the final frontier and Star Trek
6 the undiscovered country and if you
happen to be equally enthralled by Star
Trek The Next Generation you're very
much in luck
1998 Star Trek insurrections start
streaming that very same day as a wise
man once said live long and prosper our
prediction in early 2020 The Goonies
will once again be good enough for you
down here on New Year's Day Amazon Prime
video starts streaming the classic 1985
adventure comedy yell gasp you'll giggle
as lovable children trek through
underground caves in search of buried
treasure
all while outmaneuvering a slew of
baddies and booby traps
wanna wrestle wanna laugh thanks to the
2019 film fighting with my family you
can do both based on the true story of
WWE wrestler Paige this comedic biopic
tells the story of suryya
age Beavis played by Florence Pugh who
finally gets her shot at superstardom in
the wrestling ring a certain Dwayne the
rock Johnson co-stars playing himself
the film comes to Amazon Prime on
January 30th horror hounds take heed
you're cordially invited to kick off the
new year with every manner of chills and
thrills available on Amazon Prime
beginning January 3rd mid Samar tells
the story of a troubled American couple
checking out a mysterious festival in
Sweden their trip and the relationship
quickly devolves into a druggy darkly
comic disaster this is the sec
full-length film directed by re aster
who made a name for himself with his
hair racing debut hereditary myth Samar
is yet another exercise in mounting
dread and its myriad horrors dare to
unfold in broad daylight
honestly this full core film makes the
wicker man look like Encino man
meanwhile if you're in the mood for some
freaky futuristic fare we've got some
good news for you the entire cube series
will be available to stream starting on
January 1st
including cube cube to hypercube & cube
0 run don't walk each cube film involves
a group of strangers trapped in a
massive structure outfitted with
futuristic booby traps let it suffice to
say things get very dicey indeed and
hooray there's so much more to fear in
the new year on January 1st you can
check out Robin Williams in the final
cut the film is set in a dismal future
in which everyone's lives are recorded
from start to finish and Williams edits
those recordings for funerals his life
takes a turn for the worse when he's
asked to hand over the memories of a
recently deceased millionaire that's not
all in knowing Nicolas Cage stars as a
neurotic fellow who finds a list of
numbers in a time capsule and comes to
believe there's a world ending disaster
on horizon
you can check it out on Amazon Prime
starting on January 1st happy New Year
to all the impending apocalypse
notwithstanding craving adventure not to
worry on January 1st you can take a
close look at 2009 s Sherlock Holmes an
overly slick reimagining of the 19th
century sleuth Robert Downey jr. stars
as the titular hero and Jude Law plays
his ever loyal partner dr. Watson the
film involves a dastardly jerk by the
name of Blackwood played by Mark Strong
who has more than a passing interest in
the Black Arts
after being executed for a series of
brutal slayings throughout London he
seems to have risen from the grave
soon enough Holmes and Watson are
splashing headfirst into the darkest
margins of the occult in order to solve
a diabolical mystery if swords and
sorcery are more your thing 2011's Conan
the Barbarian will be available on
Amazon Prime starting on January 6 the
film stars Jason
as an exceptionally strong warrior who
blazes a trail of righteous vengeance
across the land grunting all the while
meanwhile his confirmed nemesis is
trying to get his hands on a magical
mask that will give him incredible
powers can conan conquer him and save
civilization from dark supernatural
forces we're guessing he can and will or
will be wanting our money back to Amazon
Prime originals are coming your way in
January and neither should be missed if
you know what's good for you before his
1989 execution in the state of Florida
serial killer Ted Bundy confessed to
killing 30 women between 1974 and 1978
and many people suspect the list of
victims is even longer than that
available on Amazon beginning January
31st Ted Bundy falling for a killer is a
five-part docu-series that looks at this
horrific human being through the eyes of
the women who knew him this story has
been told many times by men now's the
time to talk about our own story from
beginning to end too bleak for you not
to worry in troop zero a young girl
named Christmas Flint played by McKenna
grace is determined to get in contact
with extraterrestrials see she's
obsessed with outer space because she
hopes her dead mother can be found
amongst the stars
so imagine her delight when she hears
that NASA wants regular folks like her
to contribute to a very special project
we are putting together a record of life
to launch into space we will be
recording people at the Jamboree
you better believe the birdie Scout
Jamboree is a talent show and we should
probably mention that Christmas Flint is
considered something of an outcast among
her snippy close minded peers the
question is can Christmas rally a troupe
of friends together and put on a killer
show in order to finally make her mark
on the universe well we certainly hope
so find out for sure on January 17th
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and TV shows are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the belt so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]